麥克風
麥克風沒開
我們可以拿輕點吧
好 各位媒體們 媒體朋友們 大家好
那今天呢主要是公布呢
我们今天呢已经正式公告的
我们修正了公布注意跟处置的一个相关规定
那公布注意跟处置的相关规定呢
我们是在民国84年定的
那最主要的用意呢
就是在有价证券呢
涨跌有异常波动的时候呢
可以适度去提醒投资人呢
注意交易的风险
那这个措施呢
原本就是维持市场秩序的中性的措施
那到目前呢
已经因应了各个阶段市场的变化呢
我们也历经多次的检讨修正
那为了要落实公平
安全跟透明的资本市场的管理规则呢
并提升交易的效率
所以證交所這邊呢
從上半年呢就開始啟動呢
相關的機制的一個檢視
那我們中和考量的近期市場的變化
那過去呢
實施成效跟相關的影響
以及各界呢
對注意及處置相關規定的一個建議以後呢
那證交所這邊呢
修正了處置有價證券的處置期間
撮合作业的时间
以及公布注意交易资讯的标准
那这个修正案呢
我们今天公告
那从115年8月10号呢
正式实施
那以下呢为各位报告一下呢
修正的相关内容
第一项就调整处置的期间
那第一次跟第二次呢
含以上呢
招发布处置的有价证券
那处置期间呢
修改为5个营业日
原来呢是10个营业日
那第二点呢
如果招发布处置的有价证券呢
在计算发布处置基数的期间内呢
同时有因为呢
当中交易占比过高
而公布注意交易资讯者
那原本的处置期间是12个营业日
修正后呢
缩短为7个营业日
那第二项是调整普通交易
有在证券的撮合作业时间
那第一次跟第二次的以上的
那个被发布处置的普通交易的有下证券呢
其撮合作业时间呢
我们参考呢
目前呢
瞬间价格稳定措施
暂缓戳合的时间
调整为呢
每两分钟
戳合一次
那原来的规定是
第一次处置是五分钟
第二次处置是二十分钟
那现在余率呢
所改为两分钟
那第三点呢
一修正公布注意
第十一款
六个营业日收盘价
起期价差的一个标准
那依照修正以后的规定
当日呢收盘价呢超过1000块以上的
而且最近6个营业日
收盘价起期价差达300元以上
才适用本款的一个规定
所以当收盘价超过2000元呢
价差的金额调整为每1000元为一个集聚
那每一个急剧的价差呢
增加150块
所以有可能呢
是用这项规定的话呢
我们原本是最近6个营业日
那个收盘价差呢
在100块以上就可能是用
那价差每500块为一个急剧
每一个急剧是加25块
这是原来规定
那现在放宽了
所以举个例子来说的话呢
股价超过1000块到2000块之间呢
价差的标准是300元
那价差呢超过2000元到3000元的
价差的标准就是300块再加150块
就是450块
那以后呢以此类推
那本次修正以后呢
我们将建立一个定期检查
检视的一个机制
原则上呢
我们每半年会定期去检讨
来因应股市的一个相关的变化
接着跟会报告
修正规定以后的实施
如果目前还在处置期间内的有价证券
怎么去试用
原则上有以下三点
第一点
已经符合修正后处置的日数者
从实施日起即解除处置
例如呢
依照新规定处置五个营业日或七个营业日者
如果到实施日前呢
已经处置期满的话呢
就从实施日起呢
解除处置
那第二点
如果还没有符合新规定的处置日数的话
则处置到届满五个营业日或七个营业日为止
例如截至实施日仅处置三个营业日的
仍需呢
持续处置到五个营业日满
或七个营业日满
就解除了
那第三点
从修正规定实施日起呢
除了变更交易方法
变更交易方法
且采行分盘交易者呢
其余受处置有价证件的戳合时间呢
一律都改產 每兩分鐘 撮合一次
那以上就是這一次的一個修正
請問各位媒體朋友有沒有問題
台股量能的益柱會是多少應該是這是一個中性的處置
主要功能在提醒投資人
注意交易的風險
所以我們並沒有去估計
對量能的一個影響
量能還是要回歸到基本面
以及中和各種
國際上的政經變化的一個情況
為什麼沒有考慮到一次乾脆取消
這個我們很努力的在有各種方案的討論
然後請我們監事部經理師簡單說明一下
我們這次的調整呢
是希望能夠兼顧適度的提醒
跟維持必要的流動性
所以呢
我們把每次的5分鐘
跟20分鐘的交易
縮成2分鐘一次
事實上
我們的市場
當初也是從2分鐘
慢慢縮減成
到現在的足比交易
但剛才發言有報告
我們未來會定期的檢討
不管是數據方面
我們現在這次的調整
是先從縮短時間
跟縮短處置的日期開始
未來我們承諾
每半年都會做一次調整
以上報告
副總請教一下
之前有人在批評說
處置股在大漲
就是各股大漲的時候也處置
可是大跌的時候也處置
這個部分你可以說明嗎
有研究過
市場監禮的措施
基本上是一個中性的措施
那漲跟跌
基本上我們都不能
都要兼顧
這漲跟跌的部分
所以換句話說
我們在所有的處置規定裡面
都是漲跟跌是並列的
所以呢
我們不可能因為漲的部分或跌的部分
造成大家可能覺得會助長或助跌
而造成它的不平衡
剛剛跟各位報告過
就是這是一個中性的機制
所以我們實施這個制度
本身的用意就是在有價證券
漲跌波動很大的時候
去提醒投資人注意他的交易的安全
所以不管漲或是跌
我们都会提醒
上礼拜就是整个台股大跌
然后造成很多储置股
因为没有量
储置的时间拉长
就是成交的时间拉长
所以造成很多股票
它是卖不出去的
针对这个部分
我們有沒有再去做一個整體的考量
就是這個部分有沒有可能
有特別的
就剛剛有提到
半年後會檢討一次
那半年之後
有沒有可能針對這個部分
如果還有這樣的一個情況發生的話
在國際上他們是有這樣的一個制度嗎
類似的制度不完全一樣
然後說之前處置好像我們這邊有分析過並沒有賣不出去的狀況
是流通性會稍微受一些影響
但是還沒有發生說賣不掉
休聖要不要說
我想處置大家最在意的應該是預收款券的問題
那預收款券的確會造成流動量降低
那麼當然也是另外一個角度
預收款券也是為了市場的秩序跟交割的安全
我們希望能夠降低交割的風險
所以才有預收款券這個制度
那當然未來各種可能性的考量
我們都不會排除
所以我們跟大家報告說
半年我們會來檢討
不管是量化方面或者是交易方面
報告想請教
就是像之前有討論到熔斷的機制
其他國家都有
那既然剛才講所有可能性都有在討論
那是不是有討論到壟斷機制導入的可能性
我們目前並沒有考慮壟斷機制
像壟斷的話
美國有這個機制
然後韓國有這個機制
那美國是沒有漲跌幅的限制
那韓國是漲跌幅是30%
那台灣漲跌幅只有10%
所以相較之下
我們並沒有要採取熔斷機制
但是我們有一個動態的盤中的價格穩定措施
就是那個價格變動相差3.5%的時候
我們會暫緩戳合2分鐘
所以大概也一樣會有冷卻的功能存在
還有沒有其他問題呢
還蠻巧合的就是在上個禮拜就有網路在討論
然後上午也有委員在討論
然後下午就這個制度就更改
這我想不可能就是說制度這麼快就去改變
但如果有聽說好像券商公會這邊
其實券商這邊好像有些也不太知道這個改的過程
那想說這個
大概花了什麼多久時間去討論這個30年
應該是美洲新30年第一次改這個制度
大概這個調整的過程
花了多久時間去討論這件事情
謝謝
OK
我們每次調整呢
都會去跑一下呢
過去執行的狀況
歷史的數據
那不斷的修正
那也分析一下呢
就是每次處置之後呢
對這些受處置的個股的一個相關的影響性
那不斷的在想呢
什麼方式比較好
所以不是效率高是效率很慢啊
我們研究了半年以上
那因為我們說大概
以後也是大概半年會去檢討一次謝謝在處置前會先有警示你們有針對這些警示的一些很多的項目去討論到這部分的內容
剛才發言人報告的
我們對於每一個數字我們都有去試跑過
那當然這個整個決策的過程我們做了半年左右
今天自他出第一步啦
所以未來我們當然會再做再根據市場的狀況
我們會做更深入的研究跟數據的探討
請問現場還有媒體需要提問的嗎
不好意思再問一個
就是因為之前有人覺得說盤中的監視制度
其實還是有它的人為裁量的這個空間在
那我不確定說在這次的改變
當然我們像剛才陳如的長官講的
這只是第一步而已
那我不確定未來會不會進一步
就是減少那個人為裁量的這個空間
而增加是以制度作為基礎的
這個處置的這個規則這樣子
對 謝謝
監視制度基本上
我們的標準都放在官網上面
所以沒有人為裁量的這種事情
都是按照數據電腦跑出來的結果
所以呢
各位可以在我們的官網上面看到所有監視的標準
不管是周轉率
不管是當充比率
不管是等等的各種數字
漲跌等等
通通都是有數字做著正的
所以絕對沒有人為裁量這種事情
我們每一款都會有量化的標準
所以你去看一下我們相關的規定
說實在 叫我算完真的算不出來
所以事先都是透過電腦層次去設定
所以算出來的數字是死的
所以很難有人為考量的空間
8月10號的生效是按照8月10號當天公布
隔日開始實施還是按照8月7號
對 禮拜五是8月7號公布
從8月11號開始實施
法規的公告
法規的公告今天就实施了
所以在处置期间的
就是适用新的这些期间的规定
然后8月10号应该是
8月10号必须处置的
开始适用新的规定
所以各位手上都有一张对照表
这张对照表呢
就把中間從今天開始到禮拜五
中間過渡期間的所有處置股票
那麼它的適用狀況
跟給大家給證券商給投資人一目了然
可以看得出來
那麼8月10號以後就完全適用新的標準
比如說我們那個新聞稿里面的第五項
我們就有去區分
就说我们今天法规已经公告了
所以如果已经符合修正后的处置日数的话
看怎么去计算
如果还没有符合的话怎么算
那8月10号以后就完全是新的计算方式
请问现场还有媒体需要提问的吗
最近媒體也都很關注的
擔保維持率的一個問題
我在這裡說明
其實證交所一直都是秉持
資訊透明
投資人保護
以及市場穩定的三項原則
为证券市场及投资人提供服务
这也是证交所很重要的工作
资讯透明是证交所的责任
更强调市场上所需要的是负责任
当责的资讯的透明机制
近期内因为有部分媒体频繁报导
引用一些不是很完整的计算因子去推估融資的擔保維持率
那這個部分並不是投資人整戶擔保維持率
所以為了要避免引發市場不必要的疑慮跟投資人的誤解
所以交易所這邊會適時去說明
那這個課題交易所也會持續研議
跟主管機關持續的去溝通
那我们比较呢
其实媒体所报道推估的担保维持率呢
是指的是个股的担保维持率
那我们在市场的监理方面呢
其实担保维持率的概念是这样
是证券商跟投资人之间的关系
因为证券商把钱呢
或是股票借给了投资人
那会收一些担保品
所以他是在控管他的受信的風險
所以對個別個別投資人
都會計算一個擔保的維持率
那是對個別的客戶
他的計算基礎是算整戶
比如說對A客戶是算A客戶的擔保維持率
對B客戶是B客戶的擔保維持率
那他整戶的概念是
他包括所有的上市上櫃
因为不管借什么
都是券商把钱或股票借给他们
所以包括上市上櫃
也包括融资跟融券都一起算
所以担保维持率过低的时候
他就会发出通知信函
给投资人说他应该要补缴担保品
所以证券商不会去看个股的
個股跟投資人說實在也沒有直接的關聯性
因為投資人關心的是
他到底跟券商借了什麼東西呢
當保品夠不夠呢這個才是比較重要的所以針對這个部分呢大概我们做一个观念上的一个澄清然后我们有写一个比较完整的说明
主信有给他们吗
对
然后给各位媒体朋友们呢
做一个参考
请问现场的媒体记者们
有问题需要提问的吗
好 那現場的媒體記者沒有問題需要提問
那請問副總這邊還有要繼續說明的事項嗎
OK 那如果大家沒有問題的話
那我們記者會就到這邊結束
謝謝大家
好 謝謝
好
我可以看到你
謝謝大家
好
字幕志愿者 李宗盛
谢谢大家